hey guys it is Friday this is your top
five gaming news show and I'm wearing
something ridiculous that we'll get to
that in a second believe it or not one
of the biggest things making waves in
gaming this week was this xbox onesie
created by Xbox Australia it's got
pockets for your game controller your
media devices your phone but I'm still
yet to find one for my dignity the
onesie also features a gigantic hood big
enough for your headphones forearm grips
to prevent slipping although I don't
know why you would be slipping rollable
sleeves and customized gamertag
embroidery Microsoft haven't revealed
whether these will actually go on sale
at any time but they are running a cup
to let you win one on their Facebook
page if you're an Australian resident in
case this is a thing you need in your
life 15 million of you have stopped
playing Pokemon go over the last month
but for the 30 million still playing
Niantic have made some changes in a new
update Pokemon Joe's latest update
introduces the Pokemon appraisal feature
which lets you roughly assess your
critters relative attack defense and
stamina capabilities as measured by
their team leader this seems to suggest
you can't use this feature until you
choose a team at level 5 whether that be
team mystic team valor or Hufflepuff the
attack and defense stats will influence
how well your pokemon fight in gyms the
update also adds minor bots fixes and
Niantic says they're working on several
new features to be implemented later
this week Sony announced that
PlayStation Plus subscription prices are
getting a hike in the US and Canada this
will be the first time the subscription
prices have gone up since the service
launched in 2010 you'll now be paying
59.99 instead of 50 bucks for 12 months
and it will be $24.99 for 3 months if
you want to continue playing online and
getting those monthly PlayStation Plus
games the price of the monthly plan is
staying at 990
Sonia explained on the playstation blog
that the new pricing reflects the
current market conditions in Canada the
yearly price will now be seventy bucks
three-month subscriptions will cost
thirty bucks and the monthly price will
be twelve bucks the new prices will take
effect if your membership renews on or
after September 22 some footage of an
Xbox Live Arcade version of Goldeneye
double-oh-seven was doing the rounds
earlier this week and Xbox boss Phil
Spencer decided to wing it
while starry-eyed fans looked on with
nostalgia and disappointment that the
rumored Xbox 360 version never came to
fruition
Spencer explained on Twitter goldeneye
has always been a rights issue not a
getting code to run issues that may also
explain why Goldeneye was not included
in the 30 game breviary play package
that came out last year allegedly the
game was in development for Xbox Live
Arcade at rare in 2007 and 2008 but
Nintendo Japan ended up shutting the
project down just months before its
planned release currently Activision
holds the James Bond video game license
finally to new ps4 models are going to
be revealed in September according to a
new report The Wall Street Journal
leaked so that a new ps4 standard model
would be arriving alongside a new
upgraded ps4 citing sources familiar
with the matter it's likely we'll hear
more at Sony's PlayStation event that's
scheduled for September 7 Sony already
confirmed they are working on a more
powerful ps4 codenamed near which will
feature improved graphics and forecasts
for later this past week images leaked
of the ps4 slim and its new controller
which was purchased by a UK resident
through the Craigslist esque website
Gumtree you're a gamer headed over to
the dudes house and confirmed that it is
in fact the real deal the considerably
smaller ps4 appears to have rounded
corners and the PlayStation symbol comes
bottom while the new controller features
a second light bar on the front this
week on site we give you the lowdown on
the best graphics cards chat about
what's new in WWE 2k 17 and give you our
verdict on time for two's multiplayer
that is everything from me this week
thanks so much for sticking around have
a great weekend
I will see you again on Monday